[موسيقى]
تحليل الوضع التونسي لازم يكون مربوط بما
صار بعد ثوره قبل الثوره التونسيه
بطريقه المستويه
على مستوى السنوات والعشرات السنوات ان
شاء الله احنا في طريق همم الصحيح وفي
تونس هناك طبقه مثقفه من اعلى تراس من
اعلى تيرانس من في جميع المجالات في جميع
المجالات طب والرقمنا والتكنولوجيا
والتعليم والعديد من المجالات وهذه الطبقه
المثقفه خاصه في السنوات وفي فتره هذا
البناء زادت في القوه وزادت في الثقافه
وما شاء الله عليهم وخاصه عن النخبه وعن
الشباب
[موسيقى]
جهويه كبيره همم يعني همم في الصحه وفي
التعليم وفي الماليه اتمنى تونس انها
تستثمر اكثر في خيرات هو تاريخها وحضارتها
كفلاحتها وفي الفلاحه وفي السياحه وغيره
في المعهد همم التاريخيه الكبيره اللي
عندها
واتمنى لي همم
تونس كانت بتكنولوجيا العراقي في مجال
القبائل في مجال الصناعي وتكون رائده في
هذا المجال واتمنى كذلك ان تونس ان شاء
الله تكون هي اكثر من بوابه من افريقيا
بحكم القرابه
الافريقيه بحكم يعني ال- ال- الجغرافيه
الثقافيه وبحكم
كذلك رجال الاعمال التونسيين بالاسواق
الافريقيه ممكن تساعد دول العربيه الاخرى
والدول الاوروبيه وغيره
[موسيقى]